dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on I say here this
paper is about interactively modeling
and editing climbing plants this is one
of my favorite kind of works mundane
founding topic immaculate execution
there are so many cool things about this
paper I don't even know where to start
but first let's talk about the modeling
part we can for instance plant a seed
and we can not only have a look at how
it grows as time goes by but we can also
influence the grow variability and shoot
growth rates branches can be added and
removed at will at any point in time we
can also add attractors regions that are
set to be more likely for the plant to
grow towards with these techniques we
can easily create any sort of artistic
effect be it highly artificial looking
vines and branches or some
long-forgotten object overgrown with
climbing plants however a model is just
3d geometry what truly makes these
models come alive is animation which is
also executed with flying colors the
animations created with this technique
are both biologically and physically
plausible so what do these terms mean
exactly biologically plausible means
that the plants grow according to the
laws of nature and physically plausible
means that if we start talking at it
branches start moving bending and
breaking according to the laws of
physics
due to its responsive and interactive
nature the applications of this
technique are typically in the domain of
architectural visualization digital
storytelling or any sort of real-time
application and of course the usual
suspect animated movies and game
developers can use this to create more
immersive digital environments with ease
and don't forget about me Kari who would
happily play with this basically all day
long if you are one of our many fellow
scholars who are completely addicted to
two minute papers make sure to check out
our patreon page where you can grab cool
perks like watching these episodes in
early access or deciding the order of
upcoming episodes and more also your
support is extremely helpful so much so
that even the price of a cup of coffee
per month help
to create better videos for you we write
some reports from time to time to assess
the improvements we were able to make
with your support the link is in the
video description or you can just click
the letter key on the ending screen in a
moment thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time
[Music]
you